Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Welcome to The Rest Is History, our very first on-location recording. And Tom Holland, with our unerring eye for glamour, we have chosen this fantastic spot. It's literally a roundabout. Yeah. We're in the middle of a roundabout, but it's a distinguished roundabout because it's Trafalgar Square. You can hear the police going by. Yeah, police going by you're shouting over the siren that's how i like to think we'll uh confirming your darkest suspicions of london um we're in we're standing
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的加更节目、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。欢迎来到《历史的余味》，这是我们首次进行外景录制。汤姆·霍兰德，凭借我们对魅力独到的眼光，我们选择了这个绝佳地点。这实际上是一个环岛。没错。我们正处于环岛中央，但这是一个尊贵的环岛，因为它是特拉法加广场。你能听到警车经过的声音。是的，警车经过，你得在警笛声中大声说话，我喜欢认为我们正在证实你对伦敦最阴暗的猜想，嗯，我们正站在
beneath the statue of charles i which is london's oldest bronze statue it is um and is in fact the the center of lond, isn't it? Because this is where the Eleanor Cross used to stand. Yeah. So the cross was taken down in 1647. So these were the crosses put up by Edward I in memory of his wife, Eleanor of Castile. And on this spot,
查理一世的雕像下，这是伦敦最古老的青铜雕像，它实际上是伦敦的中心，不是吗？因为这里曾经矗立着埃莉诺十字架。是的。十字架在1647年被拆除了。这些十字架是爱德华一世为纪念他的妻子卡斯蒂利亚的埃莉诺而竖立的。而在这一地点，
we have this bronze statue of Charles I, which went up in 1633 so during his lifetime so this isn't a statue commemorating someone who's dead unlike most of the statues that we're going to be talking about today because that's what we're doing isn't it we're talking statues so that's why we've come here so obviously trafalgar square got charles i but we've also got nelson we've got a load of uh generals who ken livingston famously didn't know who they were and wanted to take them down. And then we may go down and look at Parliament Square and look at the statues there as well.
我们有这座查理一世的青铜雕像，它建于1633年，也就是在他生前，所以这并不是一座纪念死者的雕像，这与我们今天将要讨论的大多数雕像不同，因为这就是我们今天要做的，不是吗？我们在讨论雕像，所以这就是我们来到这里的原因，显然特拉法加广场有查理一世，但我们也有纳尔逊，我们还有一大堆将军，肯·利文斯通曾因不知道他们是谁而想把他们拆除。然后我们可能会走下去看看议会广场，也看看那里的雕像。
Statues are obviously a very hot-button issue. So I think this is a perfect place to do our first on-the-spot broadcast. And the question, Tom, keep or cancel? I think we should ask keep or cancel. Yes. OK. So should we focus on Charles I? Yeah, like art collector. Because as you say, I mean, this was not intended to go up in a public space. So this was for a private garden. Is that right?
雕像显然是一个非常热门的话题。所以我认为这是我们进行首次现场广播的完美地点。汤姆，问题是，保留还是取消？我想我们应该问保留还是取消。是的。好的。那么我们应该关注查理一世吗？是的，比如艺术收藏家。因为正如你所说，我的意思是，这本来不是为了放在公共场所的。所以这是为了一个私人花园。是这样吗？
Yeah. So it was one of Charles I's kind of big supporters. And then obviously Civil War happened and Charles I had his head chopped off just down the road actually just down towards um and so parliament ordered this to be destroyed but it got it got hidden and then with the restoration in 1660 it went straight back up yeah um and it got put in this place i think 1675 or something yeah and looking looking weirdly looking down at the spots of his own death yes which is a sort of strange and also of course looking down at the spot of his own death. Yes. Which is a sort of strange... And also, of course, looking down towards Parliament, where there is a statue of Oliver Cromwell. Yeah, it's great that they're facing each other, isn't it?
是的。所以他是查理一世的忠实支持者之一。然后显然内战爆发了，查理一世的头就在路那头被砍掉了，实际上就在那边，所以议会下令摧毁它，但它被藏了起来，然后在1660年王政复辟时，它又被放回去了，是的，它被放在了这个位置，我想是1675年左右，是的，而且奇怪地俯视着他自己死亡的地点，是的，这是一种奇怪的感觉，当然也俯视着他自己死亡的地点。是的。这是一种奇怪的感觉……而且，当然，俯视着议会方向，那里有一座奥利弗·克伦威尔的雕像。是的，他们面对面真是太棒了，不是吗？
It is. And obviously, we're going to be talking about whether, you know, whether it's right that statues of certain people should be up in... Yes. I've always felt that having a statue of Charles I at one end of Whitehall, the great avenue, the artery of power in London, and a statue of Cromwell at the other is kind of the perfect compromise. It's the perfect way to memorialize the Civil War. It's the physical embodiment of our podcast that said that everything was 17th century, isn't it?
确实。显然，我们将讨论某些人的雕像是否应该竖立在……是的。我一直觉得在白厅（伦敦权力的动脉）的一端竖立查理一世的雕像，在另一端竖立克伦威尔的雕像，是一种完美的妥协。这是纪念内战的完美方式。这是我们播客的物理体现，我们说过一切都是17世纪的，不是吗？
Yes, it is. That's what it is. It is. So, come on, Tom, would you get rid? Would you keep? Oh, I'd definitely keep it. Yeah, I've got to keep it. But you'd have to keep Cromwell as well. Well, we will come to that.
是的，确实如此。就是这样。所以，来吧，汤姆，你会拆除吗？你会保留吗？哦，我肯定会保留。是的，我必须保留。但你也得保留克伦威尔。嗯，我们会谈到那一点的。
Because that's a bit more controversial. But I think also Charles I is a great one to start with. Because as you said, it's the oldest statue here, really. And it focuses the question on why do statues exist? So the whole debate about, you know, what statues should we have? Should we have statues at all? It's not a given that statues stand. For the middle ages, 16th century, they didn't have statues like this. So why did they suddenly appear? And then going into the 19th century, into the 20th century, why is there a sudden glut?
因为那更具争议性。但我认为查理一世也是一个很好的切入点。因为正如你所说，它是这里最古老的雕像。它将问题聚焦于为什么会有雕像？所以关于我们应该拥有什么雕像的整个辩论，我们是否应该拥有雕像？雕像的存在并不是理所当然的。在中世纪、16世纪，他们没有这样的雕像。那么为什么它们突然出现了呢？然后进入19世纪、20世纪，为什么突然出现了一大批？
And I think that probably the best way to answer that is to go and look at another statue in Trafalgar Square, which is a statue of Charles's son, James II, which stands in front of the National Gallery and is a good deal less noisy. So let's go there. Okay. So Tom, we're approaching this next statue, which is one you're very keen on because I think it's going to fit your thesis, isn't it? It does, which is why I wanted to bring you here. I mean, as I approach, it's like, what is it, a Roman? Well, so it's James II. Okay. Son of Charles I.
我认为回答这个问题的最好方法是去看看特拉法加广场的另一座雕像，那是查理一世的儿子詹姆斯二世的雕像，它矗立在国家美术馆前，而且安静得多。所以我们去那里吧。好的。汤姆，我们正在接近下一座雕像，这是你非常感兴趣的一座，因为我认为它会符合你的论点，不是吗？确实如此，这就是我带你来这里的原因。我的意思是，当我走近时，它看起来像什么，一个罗马人？嗯，这是詹姆斯二世。好的。查理一世的儿子。
Yes. Younger brother of Charles II. Famously kicked out in the Glorious Revolution of 1688. So this is Grinling Gibbons, put up in 1686, two years before he got kicked out. So he's only been king for a year. It's not a memorial to uh to a great king but he's as you say dressed in in roman armor he's got a cloak he's got a he's got the little thigh boots um yeah and it it focuses attention on the roots of this sudden mania for putting up statues because until this point you're not putting up statues of kings which is why there aren't statues of edward the fourth
是的。查理二世的弟弟。因1688年的光荣革命而被赶下台。所以这是格林林·吉本斯的作品，建于1686年，在他被赶下台前两年。所以他只当了一年国王。这不是为了纪念一位伟大的国王，但正如你所说，他穿着罗马盔甲，披着斗篷，穿着大腿靴，嗯，它将注意力集中在突然兴起的竖立雕像热潮的根源上，因为在此之前，你不会竖立国王的雕像，这就是为什么没有爱德华四世
or richard the third or there is supposedly so there is supposedly an older statue which is out of king alfred which is said to have been sculpted in the reign of richard the second okay um put up in westminster and then moved to Southwark. But actually it's pretty clear it's Victorian. I think there's a portrait bust of Elizabeth the first on St. Dunstan's on Fleet Street. But aside from that, it's really here that it begins. And the fact that he's in Roman dress shows that what's going on here is an attempt to ape and mimic Roman styles. And it's in Greece and Rome that you put up statues of emperors, obviously,
或理查三世的雕像，或者据说有一座更古老的阿尔弗雷德大帝的雕像，据说是在理查二世统治时期雕刻的，好的，放在威斯敏斯特，然后搬到了南华克。但实际上很明显它是维多利亚时代的。我想在舰队街的圣邓斯坦教堂上有一座伊丽莎白一世的半身像。但除此之外，它确实是从这里开始的。他穿着罗马服装的事实表明，这里发生的是一种模仿罗马风格的尝试。显然，在希腊和罗马，你会竖立皇帝的雕像，
but also great men, because it's the best way to memorialize them. You don't have photographs, you don't have other ways of preserving their memory. So you put the statues up. Why are there no statues in the Middle Ages? Because they've fallen out of habit with the fall of the Roman empire, but also with the, and you will know what I'm about to say. It's Christianity. The coming of Christianity. So there is, Christianity brings a deep anxiety about
但也包括伟人，因为这是纪念他们的最好方式。你没有照片，没有其他保存他们记忆的方式。所以你竖立雕像。为什么中世纪没有雕像？因为随着罗马帝国的衰落，这种习惯已经消失了，而且，你会知道我要说什么。是基督教。基督教的到来。所以，基督教带来了对
graven images. So you will get, you will obviously. Statues of saints. You will get statues of saints and you'll get statues of biblical kings. And on tombs, of course you get images of kings and of knights and of effigies. But you don't get standalone statues like this. And really, this is an importation from Renaissance Italy. But is it also, I mean, he's famously an absolutist, an admirer of European absolutism. So putting up the statue is quite a strong symbol, isn't it?
雕像的深深焦虑。所以你会得到，你显然会得到。圣徒的雕像。你会得到圣徒的雕像和圣经中国王的雕像。当然，在坟墓上你会看到国王、骑士和肖像。但你不会得到像这样的独立雕像。实际上，这是从文艺复兴时期的意大利进口的。但这也是吗，我的意思是，他以专制主义者、欧洲专制主义的崇拜者而闻名。所以竖立这座雕像是一个相当强烈的象征，不是吗？
Yeah. You know, I'm a Roman emperor. I'm going to be an absolute. I mean, the inscriptions in Latin, Jacobus Secundus Dei Gratia, by the grace of God, it of yeah you know i'm i'm i'm a roman emperor i'm yes you know going to be an absolute and i mean the inscriptions in latin jacobus secundus de gratia by the grace of god king of king of england scotland france he's still claiming france at this stage as i like and fidiae defense and defender of the faith even though he's catholic um yeah well so there's a i mean he could claim that he could justifiably claim that and nobody else could because there was a title
是的。你知道，我是罗马皇帝。我要成为一个专制者。我的意思是，拉丁文铭文，Jacobus Secundus Dei Gratia，蒙上帝恩典，是的，你知道，我是罗马皇帝，是的，你知道，我要成为一个专制者，我的意思是，拉丁文铭文，Jacobus Secundus Dei Gratia，蒙上帝恩典，英格兰、苏格兰、法国国王，他当时还在声称拥有法国，正如我所喜欢的，以及信仰捍卫者，尽管他是天主教徒，嗯，是的，好吧，我的意思是，他可以声称，他可以正当地声称，没有人能，因为那是一个头衔
awarded to henry eighth when he was a Catholic. So essentially the tradition of putting up statues is a culturally contingent one that is bred of Renaissance and then early modern responses to the Roman heritage. And it exists in tension with the older christian suspicion of graven images and i think that that is something that we see right the way up to the present day tom here's the thing we're talking the keeper cancel i mean he's somebody who was canceled he was canceled he was kicked out of the country and this actually got taken down i did okay that's what i was going to ask and that so when did it come back up you know? I think it got taken down on the orders of William, and then I think William gave it, said, fine, put it back up again.
授予亨利八世的，当时他还是天主教徒。所以本质上，竖立雕像的传统是一种文化偶然的产物，源于文艺复兴时期，然后是现代早期对罗马遗产的回应。它与古老的基督教对雕像的怀疑存在张力，我认为这是我们一直看到今天的东西。汤姆，重点来了，我们正在讨论保留还是取消。我的意思是，他是一个被取消的人，他被取消了，他被赶出了这个国家，这实际上被拆除了。我做到了，好的，这就是我要问的。那么它是什么时候放回去的？我想它是根据威廉的命令被拆除的，然后我想威廉给了它，说，好吧，把它放回去。
Essentially because, of course, this is in the context of the execution of Charles I and the abolition of the monarchy. So there's a nervousness about cancelling a king. And I think that's also the other thing is that in the 17th century, when you're putting up statues of kings, you're also putting up images of the idea of monarchy and of the idea of the kingdom that he's ruling. So that's the list of all the kingdoms that you get on the base of the statue. This is an image, not just of James, but of the imperial power of the British monarchy. But here's the thing, Tom. A big theme that runs
本质上是因为，当然，这是在查理一世被处决和废除君主制的背景下。所以对于取消一位国王有一种紧张感。我认为这也是另一件事，即在17世纪，当你竖立国王的雕像时，你也在竖立君主制理念和国王统治的王国理念的形象。所以这就是你在雕像底座上看到的所有王国的列表。这不仅是詹姆斯的形象，也是英国君主制帝国权力的形象。但重点是，汤姆。一个贯穿
through this whole statue debate is, you know, you're commemorating people, you're enshrining them, you're indoctrinating the public in, you know, in what they represent. And we've been standing here now for four minutes or something. And, you know, quite a few people, it's quieter than usual, but quite a few people have walked past. They've looked at us and thought, who are these freaks holding microphones and talking to each each other but nobody has looked at that statue i mean it's just a to most people it's just a piece of decorative art isn't it yeah completely that's and that that of course is the issue for ken livingston who i think in 2000 when he was mayor of london he wanted to raise to get rid of of two other statues but we'll come down to them because I love those statues.
整个雕像辩论的大主题是，你知道，你在纪念人们，你在供奉他们，你在向公众灌输他们所代表的东西。我们已经在这里站了四分钟左右了。而且，你知道，相当多的人，比平时安静，但相当多的人走过。他们看着我们，心想，这些拿着麦克风互相交谈的怪胎是谁，但没有人看那座雕像。我的意思是，对大多数人来说，它只是一件装饰艺术品，不是吗？是的，完全是这样，当然，这就是肯·利文斯通的问题，我想在2000年他担任伦敦市长时，他想拆除另外两座雕像，但我们会谈到它们，因为我喜欢那些雕像。
Yes. But also, I think while we're on the theme of Romans and aping Rome, it would be obvious to look at the most obvious Roman monument in Trafalgar Square, which is the triumphal column, which is surmounted by Nelson. Yes. Nelson. Because the idea of erecting a massive phallic column to victory is a paradigmatically Roman one. And the debate over Nelson, so I think Afio Hirsch recently suggested that Nelson should fall. This is an ancient debate. So in Rome you have Trajan's Column, which is erected to celebrate Trajan's victories over the Dacians and was surmounted by a statue of Trajan.
是的。而且，我认为当我们讨论罗马和模仿罗马的主题时，看看特拉法加广场上最明显的罗马纪念碑是显而易见的，那就是凯旋柱，上面是纳尔逊。是的。纳尔逊。因为竖立一根巨大的阳具柱来庆祝胜利的想法是一个典型的罗马想法。关于纳尔逊的辩论，所以我认为阿菲奥·赫什最近建议纳尔逊应该倒下。这是一个古老的辩论。所以在罗马，你有图拉真柱，它是为了庆祝图拉真对达契亚人的胜利而竖立的，上面是图拉真的雕像。
That statue kind of vanished, came down some point in the Middle Ages and was replaced by a statue of St. Peter. And the current debate about whether we should pull down the statue, say, of imperial generals and replace them with somebody more in tune with the spirit of the age, it's a replication of what happened with Trajan and Saint Peter. It's an old debate. Yeah, so it's an old debate.
那座雕像消失了，在中世纪的某个时候被拆除，并被圣彼得的雕像所取代。关于我们是否应该拆除帝国将军的雕像并用更符合时代精神的人来取代他们的当前辩论，这是图拉真和圣彼得所发生事情的复制。这是一个古老的辩论。是的，所以这是一个古老的辩论。
So do you want to do Nelson next or do you want to do the intervening statues? What should we do? Let's go and look at Nelson and then look at the ones who who flank him so the nelson one we can probably carry on talking as we walk towards it so the nelson one um it's much later actually than i thought so it's 1840s um it's it's so it's not put up in the immediate aftermath of his death i think the duke of wellington backed an appeal so there was like a lot of these statues there was a big sort of public subscription and um and yeah the irony is of course he's on this statue and he's towering over but he also was a very short man so this is a you could argue it's a sort of massive act of compensation
那么你想接下来做纳尔逊还是想做中间的雕像？我们该怎么做？让我们去看看纳尔逊，然后看看那些站在他两边的人，所以纳尔逊的那座，我们可以在走向它的时候继续谈论，所以纳尔逊的那座，嗯，它实际上比我想象的要晚得多，是1840年代的，所以它不是在他死后立即竖立的，我想威灵顿公爵支持了一项呼吁，所以就像很多这些雕像一样，有一个大型的公共认购，嗯，是的，讽刺的是，当然，他在这座雕像上，他高耸入云，但他也是一个非常矮的人，所以这是一个，你可以说这是一种巨大的补偿行为
because i think he was five foot six and apparently he's not wearing his eye patch on the top is he not but his arm is missing? But his arm is missing. Yeah, but his arm is missing, exactly. So, Tom, I mean, most of our listeners will probably already know that for British listeners anyway, Nelson is one of the absolute titanic figures. He's the hero of Trafalgar. Certainly I was brought up as a boy thinking that Nelson was one of the absolutely untouchable heroic figures of British history. Well, it's Trafalgar Square.
因为我想他只有五英尺六英寸，而且显然他没有戴眼罩，不是吗？但他少了一只胳膊？但他少了一只胳膊。是的，但他少了一只胳膊，没错。所以，汤姆，我的意思是，我们的大多数听众可能已经知道了，无论如何对于英国听众来说，纳尔逊是绝对的泰坦级人物之一。他是特拉法加的英雄。我小时候确实认为纳尔逊是英国历史上绝对不可触碰的英雄人物之一。好吧，这是特拉法加广场。
So it's put up in the aftermath of his death at the Battle of Trafalgar, which essentially ensures that France can't invade Britain and establishes the supremacy of the Royal Navy for a century and more. So in that sense, it's different to the statues of Charles I and James II because this is consciously a monument to victory yeah it's a
所以它是在他死于特拉法加海战后竖立的，这从根本上确保了法国无法入侵英国，并确立了皇家海军一个多世纪的霸权。所以从这个意义上说，它与查理一世和詹姆斯二世的雕像不同，因为这自觉地是一座胜利的纪念碑，是的，它是一座
monument to british greatness yeah it is exactly and again that's you know that that is very very powerfully in the roman tradition and i guess that that's what now makes people slightly uncomfortable but the statue nelson is also different from the first two we talked about and it is you know people queue up to have their they they have their photos taken on the steps don't they i mean maybe not because they love nelson and struggling the lions but because they're aware of it as a sort of icon of britishness yes um so i think i'm not right in thinking that uh at the olympic opening ceremony when daniel craig and the queen fly past in a helicopter they fly past nelson and I can't remember what he did. He sort of looks up at them or raises his hat, or gives a little wink or something.
纪念英国伟大的纪念碑，是的，确实如此，同样，你知道，这在罗马传统中是非常非常有力的，我想这就是现在让人们感到稍微不舒服的原因，但纳尔逊的雕像也与我们谈论的前两座不同，而且，你知道，人们排队在台阶上拍照，不是吗？我的意思是，也许不是因为他们爱纳尔逊和特拉法加的狮子，而是因为他们意识到它是英国性的一种象征，是的，嗯，所以我认为我在想，在奥运会开幕式上，当丹尼尔·克雷格和女王乘直升机飞过时，他们飞过了纳尔逊，我不记得他做了什么。他好像抬头看着他们，或者举起帽子，或者眨了一下眼睛之类的。
And there are kind of bronze images that attach to the base of the collar. Scenes from the battle. Scenes from four battles made from melted iron of French cannon. And the one on the side facing towards Whitehall is a Trafalgar, and it shows one of the people firing a gun is a black sailor, a man whose name was, I've got it written down, his name was George Ryan, age 23, shooting a musket. Really?
而且柱基上有一些青铜图像。战斗的场景。用法国大炮熔化的铁制成的四场战斗的场景。面向白厅那一侧的是特拉法加，它显示其中一个开枪的人是一个黑人水手，一个名字是，我把它写下来了，他的名字是乔治·瑞安，23岁，拿着火枪。真的吗？
So it's sort of a, there's a bit of nice multiculturalism there. Well, maybe that'll preserve it. But of course, Nelson is now controversial because people argue about his relationship to slavery. There's this letter where he's supposedly defending slaving interests, which I think the consensus now seems to be the letters are forgery. And it's forged after his death by anti-abolitionists
所以这有点，那里有一点不错的多元文化主义。好吧，也许那会保留它。但当然，纳尔逊现在很有争议，因为人们争论他与奴隶制的关系。有一封信，他据称在信中为奴隶制利益辩护，我认为现在的共识似乎是这些信件是伪造的。而且是在他死后由反废奴主义者伪造的
who wanted to claim Nelson's support for their cause. Though the jury is still slightly out on that. But yes, if you want to, I mean, Nelson's one of the two people that if you want to be very iconoclastic, you say, tear Churchill down and tear Nelson down. And the want to, I mean, Nelson's one of the two people that if you want to be very iconoclastic, you say tear Churchill down and tear Nelson down. And the Nelson thing, you know, lots of people, including me, got very sort of excited about that, hot under the collar. Because Nelson is seen as synonymous with Britain and Britishness and British pride and all this stuff.
他们想声称纳尔逊支持他们的事业。尽管陪审团对此仍有分歧。但是是的，如果你想，我的意思是，纳尔逊是如果你想非常反偶像崇拜，你会说，拆掉丘吉尔，拆掉纳尔逊。而且，我的意思是，纳尔逊是如果你想非常反偶像崇拜，你会说拆掉丘吉尔，拆掉纳尔逊。而且纳尔逊的事情，你知道，很多人，包括我，对此感到非常兴奋，怒不可遏。因为纳尔逊被视为英国、英国性、英国自豪感以及所有这些东西的代名词。
But he's also, he's a kind of dashing flamboyant character. Yeah. So he has all kinds of shenanigans with Emma Hamilton. Suffered very badly from diarrhoea, Nelson. Thank you, Dominic, for someone who's supposed to be batting for the British heroes. I forgot what side I'm on, sorry. Get back on side. Yeah, he's a very charismatic figure, Nelson.
但他也是一个潇洒、浮夸的人物。是的。所以他和艾玛·汉密尔顿之间有各种各样的闹剧。纳尔逊患有严重的腹泻。谢谢你，多米尼克，对于一个应该为英国英雄辩护的人来说。我忘了我站在哪一边了，抱歉。回到正题。是的，他是一个非常有魅力的人物，纳尔逊。
Very charismatic figure. I mean, he's actually not quite Churchillian in that he had colossal flaws. But people loved him for his flaws, I think. Yeah, agreed. So you wouldn't take Nelson down, would you? I mean, come on. I wouldn't take Nelson down because I think that for as long as the French have the Arc de Triomphe, we have the right to have Nelson's column. When they take Arc de Triomphe down down we'll maybe think about and also i mean it's kind of um disarming i think hitler was planning
非常有魅力的人物。我的意思是，他实际上并不完全像丘吉尔，因为他有巨大的缺陷。但我认为人们因为他的缺陷而爱他。是的，同意。所以你不会拆掉纳尔逊，是吗？我的意思是，来吧。我不会拆掉纳尔逊，因为我认为只要法国人有凯旋门，我们就有权拥有纳尔逊柱。当他们拆掉凯旋门时，我们也许会考虑，而且，我的意思是，这有点，嗯，解除武装，我想希特勒当时正计划
to if he occupied britain he was planning to take nelson's column to berlin as a kind of victory that would have been awful and the lions so in a way the lions are symbols of britishness aren't they i suppose yeah um but it's a symbol of you, of a battle that saved Britain from what I think would have been a fairly unpleasant occupation. Gallic occupation. No one would want that. No one would want that. So I'm in favour of keeping him. Let's keep him. Very good. I'm glad to hear that. All right, Tom. So what next? What have you got next? So famously, Trafalgar Square has four plinths.
如果他占领英国，他计划把纳尔逊柱带到柏林作为一种胜利，那将是可怕的，还有狮子，所以从某种意义上说，狮子是英国性的象征，不是吗？我想是的，嗯，但这象征着你，一场将英国从我认为会是相当不愉快的占领中拯救出来的战斗。高卢占领。没有人会想要那个。没有人会想要那个。所以我赞成保留他。让我们保留他。非常好。很高兴听到这个。好吧，汤姆。那么接下来呢？你接下来有什么？所以众所周知，特拉法加广场有四个基座。
One of them is occupied by a king, so like Charles I, like James II, and that is George IV, who is almost universally recognized to have been one of our worst kings. I've got some good facts about George IV, especially for this podcast. Do you want to give them? I do. Do you know what he had for breakfast? A lot. The Duke of Wellington wrote that in 1830 he had for breakfast a pigeon and beef
其中一个被一位国王占据，就像查理一世，就像詹姆斯二世，那就是乔治四世，他被普遍认为是我们要么最糟糕的国王之一。我有一些关于乔治四世的好事实，特别是为了这个播客。你想说出来吗？我想。你知道他早餐吃了什么吗？很多。威灵顿公爵写道，1830年他早餐吃了一个鸽子和牛肉
steak pie, three parts of a bottle of Moselle a glass of dry champagne two glasses of port and a glass of brandy followed by a large dose of laudanum i think don't you think that's the kind of breakfast that needs to be memorialized in our yeah i mean i but the other thing is he was so fat he weighed 20 stone i mean hit that man on that horse is not 20 stone. He ended up thinking that he'd led the charge at Waterloo. I think he'd gone completely mad at the end. But he was so... Sir David Wilkie said he was so obese, he looked like, quote,
馅饼，四分之三瓶摩泽尔葡萄酒，一杯干香槟，两杯波特酒和一杯白兰地，随后是一大剂鸦片酊，我想你不觉得那是需要被纪念的早餐吗？嗯，我的意思是，但我另一件事是，他太胖了，他重20英石，我的意思是，那个骑在马上的男人不是20英石。他最终认为他在滑铁卢领导了冲锋。我想他最后完全疯了。但他太……大卫·威尔基爵士说他太肥胖了，他看起来像，引用，
a great sausage stuffed into the covering. Well, I think... He doesn't look like that, does he? So, I mean, a completely worthless king. Yeah. But actually, you know what? What's great is that we've done three pretty worthless kings yeah they're all i mean really useless king i mean that's why i think two of them one of them got executed one of them got driven into exile and
塞进肠衣里的一根大香肠。好吧，我想……他看起来不像那样，是吗？所以，我的意思是，一个完全毫无价值的国王。是的。但实际上，你知道吗？最棒的是我们做了三个相当毫无价值的国王，是的，他们都是，我的意思是，真的没用的国王，我的意思是，这就是为什么我认为其中两个，其中一个被处决了，其中一个被流放了，而且
one of them ended up looking like a sausage meat so yeah so i think only maybe only in britain i don't know would we have three such three awful kings memorialized in our sort of most famous square? So, yeah, George IV. The producer is saying tell everybody his dates, and I think we should. Say, Dominic, what are his dates? So he's early 19th century, isn't he? He's the regent. He's the regent for George IV when he goes mad.
其中一个最终看起来像香肠肉，所以是的，所以我认为只有在英国，我不知道，我们会有三个如此糟糕的国王被纪念在我们最著名的广场上？所以，是的，乔治四世。制片人说告诉大家他的日期，我想我们应该。说吧，多米尼克，他的日期是什么？所以他是19世纪初的，不是吗？他是摄政王。他是乔治四世发疯时的摄政王。
Dominic, when did he die? He dies in 1823. Something like that. I think something like that. Something like that. Ted Valance we had on to talk about Magna Carta, and he didn't know King John's date, so I think I can be excused not knowing George IV. Right, so that's George IV done with, with impressive scholarship and learning. Yeah, I mean, I think people are getting a lot from this podcast. And then we've got two generals that we'll come to, and then we've got the fourth Blinch,
多米尼克，他什么时候死的？他死于1823年。类似那样。我想类似那样。类似那样。泰德·瓦伦斯我们请来谈论大宪章，他不知道约翰王的日期，所以我认为我可以原谅不知道乔治四世。好吧，所以乔治四世完成了，带着令人印象深刻的学术和知识。是的，我的意思是，我认为人们从这个播客中得到了很多。然后我们有两个将军，我们会谈到，然后我们有第四个基座，
which famously has been kept empty. Okay, so the two generals, Ken Livingstone, when he was mayor of london said let's tear them down no one knows who they are they're not relevant that was as i remember he wanted he wanted to bring them down not because they were um imperialists but because he didn't know who who they were yeah they were so he said oh they could just ghastly old generals so this one charles james napier i'm almost tempted to ask the producer if he knows anything about he's shaking his head um he's got a magnificent nose james napier was no he's got really good he's got a wellington style nose he does he looks very impressive he's got a nice
众所周知，它一直空着。好的，那么那两位将军，肯·利文斯通，当他担任伦敦市长时说，让我们拆掉它们，没人知道他们是谁，他们不相关，正如我记得的那样，他想，他想拆掉它们，不是因为他们是帝国主义者，而是因为他不知道他们是谁，是的，他们是，所以他说，哦，他们可能只是可怕的老将军，所以这个，查尔斯·詹姆斯·纳皮尔，我几乎想问制片人他是否知道任何关于他的事，他在摇头，嗯，他有一个宏伟的鼻子，詹姆斯·纳皮尔不是，他有一个非常好的，他有一个威灵顿风格的鼻子，他确实，他看起来非常令人印象深刻，他有一把漂亮的
sword great so he is the man who conquered sindh in what's pakistan um in the 1840s i have sinned which in latin is pekavi so he's supposed to have said but he didn't because it was a joke in punch yeah but it's a great story that they sent this message home yes pekavi i have sinned uh but he didn't it's so disappointing but he was also he was a war hero in uh peninsula war i think yeah before that that's right um but he was he did not deny that the conquest of Sindh... Yeah, so it's erected by public subscription. The most numerous contributors being private soldiers.
剑，太棒了，所以他是那个在1840年代征服了信德（现在的巴基斯坦）的人，我犯了罪，拉丁语是pekavi，所以他被认为说了，但他没有，因为那是《笨拙》杂志上的一个笑话，是的，但这是一个伟大的故事，他们把这个消息传回家，是的，pekavi，我犯了罪，嗯，但他没有，这太令人失望了，但他也是，他是半岛战争的战争英雄，我想，是的，在那之前，那是对的，嗯，但他并没有否认征服信德……是的，所以它是通过公共认购竖立的。贡献最多的是普通士兵。
Isn't that touching? Very touching. But he didn't deny that the conquest of Sindh had been a... A rascally business. A rascally business. He said, our objects in conquering India, the object of all our cruelties, do you know what it was? Money. Money.
那不是很感人吗？非常感人。但他并没有否认征服信德是一件……无赖的事情。无赖的事情。他说，我们征服印度的目标，我们所有残暴行为的目标，你知道那是什么吗？钱。钱。
Money. Money is what he says. Every shilling of this has been picked out of blood, wiped and put into the murderer's pockets. We shall yet suffer for the crime as sure as there is a God in heaven. Yes. And he also, he kind of basically foretold the um the rebellion the rebellion 1857 yeah um and and worried that british officers and indian officers weren't kind of mixing yeah so in a way i mean to the degree that to the degree that victorian generals are woke he's a woke victorian general what do you say i well he sort of has his cake and eats it doesn't he i mean he conquers it but it says it's a crime everybody and takes all the money and then says,
钱。钱就是他所说的。每一先令都是从血泊中挑选出来的，擦干净放进凶手的口袋里。我们迟早会为这种罪行受苦，就像天堂里有上帝一样。是的。而且他还，他基本上预言了，嗯，叛乱，1857年的叛乱，是的，而且，而且担心英国军官和印度军官没有融合，是的，所以从某种意义上说，我的意思是，在维多利亚时代的将军们是觉醒的程度上，他是一个觉醒的维多利亚时代将军，你怎么说？我，嗯，他有点既要又要，不是吗？我的意思是，他征服了它，但他说这是一场罪行，每个人，并拿走了所有的钱，然后说，
oh, I'm actually a very kind person. I feel really bad about it. But isn't that Britain generally? Yeah, I mean, that's us generally. So would you cancel him? Well, I wouldn't cancel him. I mean, I wouldn't cancel anybody. Well, I might cancel someone when we get later on. I've got a few up my sleeve I might cancel just to annoy the listeners. I dread to think.
哦，我实际上是一个非常善良的人。我对此感到非常糟糕。但这不就是英国通常的样子吗？是的，我的意思是，那通常就是我们。所以你会取消他吗？嗯，我不会取消他。我的意思是，我不会取消任何人。嗯，我可能会在稍后取消某人。我袖子里有几个，我可能会取消，只是为了惹恼听众。我不敢想。
Would you keep him would you i mean you're you're more work than i am so maybe you would uh massively work i would you like to see well a crane pulling him down the truth is the truth is i don't really care i don't feel strongly about it one way or the other i'm i mean i'm inherently quite conservative yeah in that i don't like i don't like repainting our sitting room, whereas my wife is always repainting the sitting room. That's exactly the analogy that you should be reaching for. So whenever she does it, I always think, yeah, that's brilliant.
你会保留他吗？你会，我的意思是，你比我更觉醒，所以也许你会，大规模觉醒，你会想看到，嗯，一台起重机把他拉下来吗？事实是，事实是，我并不真正关心，我对此没有强烈的感受，无论哪种方式，我的意思是，我本质上相当保守，是的，因为我不喜欢，我不喜欢重新粉刷我们的客厅，而我的妻子总是重新粉刷客厅。这正是你应该达到的类比。所以每当她这样做时，我总是想，是的，那太棒了。
It's worth the hassle. Right. But left to me, I wouldn't do it. So left to me, I wouldn't do it. But if they came up with some amazing new scheme, I'm sure I'd be happy. However, having said that, two things against that. One is this thing is erected by public subscription. So I do kind of think that if something's been erected by public subscription,
这值得麻烦。好的。但留给我，我不会做。所以留给我，我不会做。但如果他们想出了一些惊人的新计划，我相信我会很高兴。然而，话虽如此，有两件事反对这一点。一是这个东西是通过公共认购竖立的。所以我确实认为，如果某样东西是通过公共认购竖立的，
in a way you kind of have a duty to honour that. I also think that it's like a building. It reminds you of a particular moment in history. And also, I'm not confident in our ability to replace it with something better. And the reason for that is that I look at the fourth plinth, which has been kept empty for long, and now is put up for public subscription. And there's a kind of melting ice cream and a fly and a cherry and things. It's not great, is it?
从某种意义上说，你有义务尊重这一点。我还认为它就像一座建筑。它提醒你历史上的特定时刻。而且，我对自己用更好的东西取代它的能力没有信心。原因是我看着第四个基座，它一直空着，现在被用于公共认购。而且有一种融化的冰淇淋、一只苍蝇、一颗樱桃之类的东西。它不太好，不是吗？
Well, I mean, the idea of putting up something kind of edgy was, you know, I mean, it was edgy the first time. But it just goes round and round. And so now it's very conventional. So in a way, the edgiest thing that you could do would perhaps be to put up a statue. Another general. Another general or an admiral or something. That would be a brave statement so i think we should take a break yes and then let's return to this issue as we walk to the other okay um
嗯，我的意思是，竖立某种前卫的东西的想法是，你知道，我的意思是，它第一次是前卫的。但它只是转来转去。所以现在它非常传统。所以从某种意义上说，你可能做的最前卫的事情就是竖立一座雕像。另一位将军。另一位将军或海军上将之类的。那将是一个勇敢的声明，所以我认为我们应该休息一下，是的，然后让我们在我们走向另一个的时候回到这个问题，好的，嗯
victorian general okay all right see you after the break i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are Talking Statues. We're here in Trafalgar Square. And we have moved on to Ken Livingston's second target,
维多利亚时代的将军，好的，好的，休息后见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐的余味》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。我们正在讨论雕像。我们现在在特拉法加广场。我们已经转向了肯·利文斯通的第二个目标，
as it was 20 years ago, Major General Sir Henry Havelock. KCB. KCB. And his brave companions in arms during the campaign in India, 1857. So this is during the rebellion that you were talking about, which used to be called the Indian Mutiny. And there's a nice um quote from havelock soldiers your labors your privations your sufferings and your valor will not be forgotten by a grateful country and again erected by public subscription so again you know you could to me tom this spot that we're on is a piece of Victorian Britain. You get a sense by being here,
正如20年前那样，亨利·哈夫洛克少将。KCB。KCB。以及他在1857年印度战役中勇敢的战友们。所以这是在你谈论的叛乱期间，过去被称为印度兵变。而且有一个不错的，嗯，来自哈夫洛克士兵的引语，你们的劳动、你们的匮乏、你们的痛苦和你们的英勇，不会被一个感恩的国家所遗忘，同样是通过公共认购竖立的，所以同样，你知道，你可以对我来说，汤姆，我们所在的这个地点是维多利亚时代英国的一部分。你通过在这里获得一种感觉，
which you wouldn't get if it were removed, of the sensibility of the age. You do. And Havelock was a morally serious figure. So he was baptist who made all his soldiers do bible classes um and performed heroically in the campaign in india i think ended up dying in luck now he died of dysentery died of dysentery so again you're yeah the flow of yeah the flow of shit which is uh um but tell me obviously now the indian mutineers it was once called the rebellion is now itself very controversial right so so this is the tension so it's as you say erected by public subscription it absolutely this is in a way a kind of a you know it's it's the equivalent of news archive it's news footage from the the 19th century. We don't have anything
如果你把它移走，你就不会得到这种感觉，关于那个时代的敏感性。你确实会。而且哈夫洛克是一个道德严肃的人物。所以他是一个浸信会教徒，让所有的士兵都参加圣经课程，并在印度战役中表现英勇，我想最终死在勒克瑙，他死于痢疾，死于痢疾，所以同样，你，是的，粪便的流动，这是，嗯，但告诉我，显然现在印度叛乱分子，它曾经被称为叛乱，现在本身非常有争议，对吧？所以，所以这就是张力，所以正如你所说，它是通过公共认购竖立的，它绝对是，从某种意义上说，这是一种，你知道，它是新闻档案的等价物，它是来自19世纪的新闻片段。我们没有任何
comparable to that. So if you want to have a feeling of that, of what it was like in the middle of the Victorian period, this is a place to come. Absolutely.
与之相比的东西。所以如果你想有一种感觉，那种感觉，维多利亚时代中期是什么样子，这是一个来的地方。绝对。
Yeah. I mean, our producer was saying to me, it's not relevant. But I mean, you've made that case about any historic artefact, I would argue,
是的。我的意思是，我们的制片人一直在对我说，它不相关。但我的意思是，你已经对任何历史文物提出了那个论点，我会争辩说，
or historic building, that they're not, in a verticom, as relevant. I mean, clearly, it's not relevant, but that's, to me, what's valuable about it. There is a counter, so there are two counter arguments to keeping it. One is that we have taken statues down from Trafalgar Square before.
或历史建筑，它们不是，用引号来说，相关的。我的意思是，显然，它不相关，但对我来说，这就是它的价值所在。有一个反驳，所以有两个反对保留它的论点。一是我们以前从特拉法加广场拆除过雕像。
So you know who was here in the 19th century but got removed? It's Edward Jenner. So we've kept the generals, but we've removed the guy who pushed for vaccinations. So why was he taken down? I think he was taken down kind of late 19th century. Right. So I'd actually be all in favor of replacing Sir Henry Havelock. But surely you could put Jenner instead of the 4th bent.
所以你知道谁在19世纪在这里但被移走了吗？是爱德华·詹纳。所以我们保留了将军，但我们移走了那个推动疫苗接种的人。所以他为什么被拆除？我想他是在19世纪末被拆除的。好的。所以我实际上会完全赞成取代亨利·哈夫洛克爵士。但你肯定可以用詹纳代替第四个基座。
Put him on the 4th bent. Yeah. Well, I would, I think that itna got moved to fourth bent yeah well well i would i think that it would be nice to bring jenna back particularly after the past year and put him back in in trafalgar square i'd be in favor of that and the other issue is that um when this got put up there were there were no people really from india in britain yeah so um this was a us and them situation in the mid-19th century. That's not the case. And if there are people of Indian descent
把他放在第四个基座上。是的。好吧，我会，我认为，它被移到了第四个基座，是的，好吧，我会，我认为，把詹纳带回来会很好，特别是在过去一年之后，把他放回特拉法加广场，我会赞成那样，另一个问题是，嗯，当这个被竖立时，英国真的没有来自印度的人，是的，所以，嗯，这是19世纪中叶我们和他们的情况。情况并非如此。如果有人是印度裔
who are Londoners, who are British, who are walking past, who find this upsetting, then I don't think it's worth keeping him. But when you get down to Parliament Square, you're going to be making that same argument about Cromwell and all the Irish people in Britain. Well, we'll come to that.
是伦敦人，是英国人，走过这里，发现这令人不安，那么我不认为保留他是值得的。但当你到达议会广场时，你将对克伦威尔和英国所有的爱尔兰人提出同样的论点。好吧，我们会谈到那一点的。
Which is what people made in the 19th century. We'll come to that. Which is what people made in the 19th century. We'll come to that. But I think that it's not for me to say. Again, I don't really care. Well, if you're going to take him down, it's definitely not for you to say. I mean, I think we can agree about that. Well, I would take him down and replace him with Jenna. Okay.
这是人们在19世纪提出的。我们会谈到那一点的。这是人们在19世纪提出的。我们会谈到那一点的。但我认为这不是我能说的。同样，我并不真正关心。好吧，如果你要拆除他，那绝对不是你该说的。我的意思是，我认为我们可以就此达成一致。好吧，我会拆除他并用詹纳取代他。好的。
Would be mine. So I'm going to cancel him. Well. But you're not. I put Jenna on the fourth plinth. I'm sick of the modern art on the fourth plinth. I'm sick of the modern art. It's not clever and it's not grown up.
会是我的。所以我打算取消他。好吧。但你没有。我把詹纳放在第四个基座上。我厌倦了第四个基座上的现代艺术。我厌倦了现代艺术。它不聪明，也不成熟。
Yeah. Now let's walk over to... There's an interesting statue over this side, which I might cancel. Okay, so a controversial... Who I think should go on the fourth plinth. An equestrian statue of Elizabeth II.
是的。现在让我们走到……那边有一座有趣的雕像，我可能会取消。好的，所以一个有争议的……我认为谁应该上第四个基座。伊丽莎白二世的骑马雕像。
Oh, he's such a monarchist. Are you hoping for... Does the Queen listen? Are you hoping for recognition? No, but I think that it would be in tune with the traditions of the square. What about Prince Philip? No, because he's not a king. Make up for his disappointments in the World Cup of Post.
哦，他是一个保皇党。你是在希望……女王听吗？你是在希望得到认可吗？不，但我认为这会符合广场的传统。菲利普亲王怎么样？不，因为他不是国王。弥补他在世界杯上的失望。
Maybe. Maybe. What about Prince Philip? No, because he's not a king. Make up for his disappointments in the World Cup of Costs. Well, maybe. Maybe. Maybe. No, I think it's... Yeah. Sir Tom Holland here. It's meant for the equestrian statue. Let's put a monocle.
也许。也许。菲利普亲王怎么样？不，因为他不是国王。弥补他在世界杯上的失望。好吧，也许。也许。也许。不，我认为它是……是的。汤姆·霍兰德爵士在这里。它是为骑马雕像准备的。让我们戴上单片眼镜。
Sir Tom Holland. That's what it's for. Decorated for... But I'm only saying that. Services to royal podcasting i'm saying that to be edgy is that edgy it's the edgiest thing you can say and it would be and it would be the first one exactly it would be the first one i beat you to it so we've got three busts here where there's someone doing some drilling so we probably shouldn't go too close it's the
汤姆·霍兰德爵士。这就是它的用途。装饰为……但我只是这么说。为皇家播客服务，我这么说是为了前卫，那是前卫吗？这是你能说的最前卫的话，而且它会是，而且它会是第一个，完全是，它会是第一个，我抢在你前面了，所以我们这里有三个半身像，有人在钻孔，所以我们可能不应该靠得太近，它是
late admirals those are admirals these are world war umals. So Jellicoe and Beatty who actually hated each other from World War I and then Admiral Cunningham from World War II. Do you know a fact about General Cunningham's bust? Is he the one who was called Mary?
已故的海军上将，那些是海军上将，这些是世界大战的。所以杰利科和贝蒂，他们在第一次世界大战中实际上互相憎恨，然后是第二次世界大战的坎宁安海军上将。你知道关于坎宁安将军半身像的一个事实吗？他是那个被称为玛丽的人吗？
I didn't know that but that's a very good fact. So he had a bust as well. He was called Mary and he had a bust. Yeah. Well, we should definitely keep him then.
我不知道那个，但那是一个非常好的事实。所以他也有一个半身像。他被称为玛丽，他有一个半身像。是的。好吧，我们绝对应该保留他。
In this bust of Admiral Cunningham there is an empty bottle of guinness drunk by the sculptor and used as a sort of centerpiece of the um of the bus now obviously nobody will cancel them presumably i mean they they helped to win the world wars surely you wouldn't get rid of them would you tom no i'll keep them and actually there's a man drilling so we can't say any more about them because um we don't want the drilling to overpower your dulcet tones. And also, it's nice to have someone called Mary. Yeah.
在坎宁安海军上将的半身像里，有一个雕塑家喝空的吉尼斯啤酒瓶，被当作半身像的中心装饰品。现在显然没人会取消他们，我想他们毕竟帮助赢得了世界大战，你肯定不会除掉他们，对吧，汤姆？不，我会留着他们。而且现在有人在钻孔，所以我们不能再多说他们了，因为我们不想让钻孔声盖过你那甜美的嗓音。还有，有个叫玛丽的人真好。是的。
So there's your female components of the square. Okay. So we are now heading back up to the National Gallery. And we're going to look at someone who I suspect, Dominic, you do think should be cancelled. Definitely, definitely. There's two things I really... As you know, Tom, I'm a very passionate anti-slavery person. And also I'm very passionate about people paying their taxes.
所以这就是广场上的女性元素。好的。我们现在要回到国家美术馆。我们要看一个人，多米尼克，我怀疑你认为他应该被取消。绝对，绝对。有两件事我真的……如你所知，汤姆，我是一个非常热情的反奴隶制人士。而且我也非常热衷于人们缴纳税款。
Yes. So any sort of tax dodger... Tax dodging slave owner. Right. I think would absolutely not belong here. And especially if they dress up with a symbol of Italian fascism, which would be awful. And as luck would have it.
是的。所以任何逃税者……逃税的奴隶主。对。我认为绝对不属于这里。特别是如果他们穿着意大利法西斯主义的象征，那将是可怕的。幸运的是。
So a slave owning, tax dodging person with a symbol of fascism. Yeah. And here we are in front of Natom. Who's this? It's George Washington. It is. Presented to the people of Great Britain and Ireland by the Commonwealth of Virginia in 1921. So here's George Washington. So this is
所以一个拥有奴隶、逃税且带有法西斯象征的人。是的。我们现在在纳托姆面前。这是谁？是乔治·华盛顿。确实是。由弗吉尼亚联邦于1921年赠送给大不列颠和爱尔兰人民。所以这就是乔治·华盛顿。所以这是
clearly a gift, I think, post-World War I. We fought together in World War I. The Commonwealth of Virginia has given this copy of the original, which is one of the most famous statues of Washington, which I think one of the most famous statues of Washington, which I think stands in the Virginia State House. It's a nice symbol of Anglo-American amity.
显然是一份礼物，我想，是在第一次世界大战后。我们在第一次世界大战中并肩作战。弗吉尼亚联邦赠送了这尊原件的复制品，这是华盛顿最著名的雕像之一，我想它矗立在弗吉尼亚州议会大厦。这是英美友好的一个很好的象征。
Would you keep or get rid? So Washington's coming down in America. That's the thing. A lot of Americans are getting rid of Washington. Isn't the story that it's it's american soil apparently because he said he would never set foot again on the soil of london is that right something like that um so yes there's a claim that he's actually on american soil again i have no strong feelings uh tell me about the um the rods the fast game the fast game so those are the the symbols um
你会保留还是除掉？所以华盛顿在美国正在被拆除。就是这样。很多美国人正在除掉华盛顿。故事不是说那是美国领土吗？显然是因为他说过他再也不会踏上伦敦的土地，是这样吗？类似那样。所以是的，有人声称他实际上又回到了美国领土上。我没有强烈的感受。告诉我关于那些棍子，法西斯，法西斯……所以那些是象征，
born by the lictors who are the bodyguards of the Roman magistrates, which then got used by Mussolini as the symbol of his movement at much the same time as this statue was donated. But what's nice about this, though, Tom, is it completes the loop, doesn't it, with the Roman connotations of Charles and James. Yes, and it's a reminder, actually, of the fact that George Washington was born a British subject. Yes. So in a way, you know, he does rank as a great Briton, I guess. I mean, I wouldn't really get rid of him
由罗马治安官的保镖——刀斧手携带，后来在这一雕像捐赠的同时，被墨索里尼用作他运动的象征。但汤姆，这尊雕像好的一点是，它完成了闭环，不是吗？与查理和詹姆斯的罗马内涵相呼应。是的，而且它实际上提醒人们，乔治·华盛顿出生时是英国臣民。是的。所以从某种意义上说，他确实算得上是一位伟大的英国人，我想。我的意思是，我真的不会除掉他，
because I think it's magnanimous of us to have him. Don't you? I think it is. Yes, it is. It's a tribute to our sporting ability to accept and defeat. It's good sponsorship. Now, we haven't had any women, other than your references to your putative statue of the Queen,
因为我认为我们能容纳他表现得很大度。你不觉得吗？我认为是的。是的，确实。这是对我们接受失败的体育精神的致敬。这是很好的赞助。现在，除了你提到的你那假想的女王雕像外，我们还没有提到任何女性，
your knighthood statue, as I call it. So I think if we go around the corner, there's a very good statue of a woman, and one that I don't think anyone in their right mind would want to. Well, although, having said that, a columnist in The Guardian, Gary Young, wrote a very passionately argued long essay arguing that all statues, you should be consistent and you should get rid of all statues.
我称之为你的爵士雕像。所以我认为如果我们绕过拐角，那里有一尊非常好的女性雕像，而且我不认为任何神志正常的人会想要除掉它。嗯，话虽如此，《卫报》的一位专栏作家加里·杨写了一篇论点非常激昂的长文，主张所有雕像，你应该保持一致，你应该除掉所有雕像。
What did you make of that? I thought it was a brilliant essay. And I thought it's argument that every statue should be brought down. So he listed people he didn't approve of. And then he listed people he did approve of. And he said that they should all come down um so he listed people he didn't approve of and then he listed people he did approve of and he said that they should all come down yeah um he just didn't believe in statues and in in memorializing people in stone as a sort of oppressive you know reminder of well essentially i mean he it was it was an anxiety about graven images um serving the the graven images threatened the moral health of the people yeah that's a very old theme and a gift to you and a gift to you you must be delighted when you saw that i was so excited
你对此有何看法？我认为这是一篇精彩的文章。我认为他主张每一尊雕像都应该被拆除。所以他列出了他不赞同的人。然后他列出了他赞同的人。他说他们都应该被拆除……所以他列出了他不赞同的人，然后他列出了他赞同的人，他说他们都应该被拆除。是的，他只是不相信雕像，不相信用石头来纪念人，这是一种压迫性的提醒，本质上，他担心的是偶像崇拜，担心偶像崇拜威胁到人民的道德健康。是的，这是一个非常古老的主题，也是给你的礼物，你看到的时候一定很高兴，我太兴奋了，
because essentially it's it's it's protestantism redux it's it's the reformation at its most passionate and uh absolutist um and i i thought you know, it had the massive benefit of being consistent and brutally honest. And it did recognise the fact that statues are not a given, that it's perfectly possible to have cities without statues. But Tom, as people said, you know, you're going to have a hard job
因为本质上这是新教的回归，这是最热情、最绝对的宗教改革。而且我认为，你知道，它有一个巨大的好处，那就是一致且极其诚实。它确实承认了雕像并非理所当然，完全有可能在没有雕像的城市生活。但汤姆，正如人们所说，你知道，你很难
persuading, you know, Stoke City supporters to get rid of the statue of Stanley Matthews. Or my team, Wolves, we have statues of Stan Cullis, Billy Wright and Sir Jack Haywood which mean a lot to I mean to Wolves fans they're a symbol of our... They're idolatry. Well we're not worshipping them. Yeah you kind of are. Well and also and also the fact that that anyone you know the whole argument about statues is well they were people of their time. Yeah. So even Stanley Matthews probably had not entirely constructed views
说服斯托克城队的球迷除掉斯坦利·马修斯的雕像。或者我的球队，狼队，我们有斯坦·库利斯、比利·赖特和杰克·海沃德爵士的雕像，这对狼队球迷来说意义重大。它们是我们的……它们是偶像崇拜。好吧，我们不是在崇拜他们。是的，你某种程度上是在崇拜。好吧，而且还有一点，关于雕像的整个争论是，他们是那个时代的人。是的。所以即使是斯坦利·马修斯可能也有不完全正确的观点，
about gender relations or Russian Empire or whatever. Everybody did. You'll always be able to find a reason. I mean, this is probably Gary Young's anxiety, that by definition, everybody who in the past will be wrong, right? But that's why
关于性别关系或俄罗斯帝国等等。每个人都有。你总能找到理由。我的意思是，这可能是加里·杨的焦虑，即从定义上讲，过去的所有人都会是错的，对吧？但这就是为什么
it's fundamentally theological because essentially he's saying that all human beings are fallen and therefore you shouldn't make idols of them. That would make us unique, of course, in the Western world in not having statues if we did get rid of all our statues.
它从根本上是神学的，因为本质上他在说所有人类都是堕落的，因此你不应该为他们制造偶像。当然，如果我们真的除掉了所有的雕像，那我们在西方世界将是独一无二的。
And obviously we were not going to. It's not going to happen. But as an argument, it was kind of bracing. We are now here, probably the last statue of this bit of the podcast, do you think? And this is Edith Cavell. So this is the nurse who was shot at dawn on October the 12th, 1915, by the Germans. She had been helping Allied servicemen trapped behind the enemy lines in the western front to escape
显然我们不会这样做。这不会发生。但作为一个论点，它令人振奋。我们现在到了这里，可能是本期播客的最后一尊雕像，你觉得呢？这就是伊迪丝·卡维尔。所以这是一位护士，于1915年10月12日黎明被德国人枪杀。她一直在帮助被困在西线敌后的盟军士兵逃脱，
she was shot um i think for as a traitor as an air she'd been a nurse a red cross nurse and she had sort of dishonored her calling in the germans eyes by working with the allies there was a huge international scandal the americans begged her not to do it. There's all kinds of state memorials in Britain. And what I also like, I mean, it's a very sort of progressive memorial in a way, because you've got this statue of her looking like a sort of Mary Poppins-ish figure, and words like humanity and sacrifice. Call the midwife vibe. Right, call the midwife, actually. But then you have the utter contradiction of the two inscriptions. So at the bottom it says, her famous quote, which she says before she dies,
她被枪杀，我想是因为被视为叛徒。她曾是一名护士，一名红十字会护士，在德国人眼中，她通过与盟军合作玷污了自己的使命。这引起了巨大的国际丑闻，美国人恳求他们不要这样做。英国有各种各样的国家纪念碑。而且我也喜欢的一点是，从某种意义上说，这是一个非常进步的纪念碑，因为你看到的这尊雕像看起来像玛丽·波平斯式的人物，还有“人道”和“牺牲”这样的词。有《呼叫助产士》的感觉。对，确实有《呼叫助产士》的感觉。但随后你又看到了两个铭文的彻底矛盾。所以在底部写着她死前说的名言，
patriotism is not enough. I must have no hatred or bitterness for anyone. And then at the top, Tom? For king and country. Patriotism is not enough. Yeah. So the two are slightly at odds with each other, aren't they? Maybe that's the solution with statues, is to put two totally conflicting messages.
爱国是不够的。我必须对任何人都没有仇恨或苦毒。然后在顶部，汤姆？为了国王和国家。爱国是不够的。是的。所以两者之间有点矛盾，不是吗？也许这就是雕像的解决方案，就是放置两条完全冲突的信息。
Yeah, maybe. Which in a way is, you know, it's the pairing of Charles I and Cromwell again. Yes, I suppose so. Maybe you have to accept that no one statue is sufficient to embody an entire message, that it can only exist in tension with something else. Statues always have multiple meanings, don't they? I mean, they can have... So there's statues in Napier and Havelock,
是的，也许吧。从某种意义上说，这又是查理一世和克伦威尔的配对。是的，我想是这样。也许你必须接受没有哪一尊雕像足以体现完整的信息，它只能在与其他事物的张力中存在。雕像总是有多重含义，不是吗？我的意思是，它们可以有……所以内皮尔和哈夫洛克有雕像，
I mean, you could see them as memorials of what Britain did wrong, if they were that way inclined, couldn't you? You could see them as emblems of sin. You don't have to see them as emblems of sainthood. I mean, obviously, Edith Cavell, she's a saint here, right? And she's the only person, I think, in this...
我的意思是，如果你倾向于那样看，你可以把它们看作是英国所做错事的纪念碑，不是吗？你可以把它们看作是罪恶的象征。你不必把它们看作是圣洁的象征。我的意思是，显然，伊迪丝·卡维尔，她在这里是一位圣人，对吧？而且我认为她是这里唯一一个……
apart from possibly Charles I, although only subsequently after his death, but she's the only person who's here because she's a martyr, a victim. The others are people who, you know, generally killed other people, whereas she's here because she was shot. So, dare I say, this is quite a Christian statue. It is. And I think that when we go on to do our second episode, when we will go down White Hill, get to Parliament Square,
除了查理一世（尽管是在他死后），她是唯一一个因为是烈士、受害者而出现在这里的人。其他人都是通常杀过人的人，而她在这里是因为她被枪杀了。所以，我敢说，这是一尊非常基督教的雕像。确实是。而且我认为当我们继续做第二集时，当我们沿着白厅走，到达议会广场，
of course, on Parliament Square, you also have Westminster Abbey, and Westminster Abbey has ten statues to martyrs there, which, again, kind of provides a, maybe a counterpoint to the braggadocio of the statues that you get there. Okay, well, that's a good
当然，在议会广场，你还有威斯敏斯特教堂，威斯敏斯特教堂有十尊烈士雕像，这又提供了一个与那里雕像的虚张声势相抗衡的对比。好的，那是一个很好的
note on which to end, I think. I don't think we've... We're not going to cancel Edith Cavell, are we? No, we're not going to cancel her. I think, do we agree with cancel George Washington? No, I think we agree to spare him. Well, I think if they decide to cancel him in America, I think we should. I think that would...
结束语，我想。我不认为我们……我们不会取消伊迪丝·卡维尔，对吧？不，我们不会取消她。我想，我们同意取消乔治·华盛顿吗？不，我想我们同意放过他。好吧，我想如果他们决定在美国取消他，我想我们应该。我想那会……
No, I think... Oh, you think hold out against Americanization? It'd be good for tourism, actually. Wouldn't all the George Washington fans would come over here over here anyway on that note i mean on that incredibly powerful insightful note um i think we should um call it a day and we will return in our next podcast with more um statues yeah more statue mongering goodbye bye you thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不，我想……哦，你认为要抵制美国化？这对旅游业其实有好处。难道所有的乔治·华盛顿粉丝不会无论如何都来这里吗？总之，在那一点上，我的意思是，在那极其有力、深刻的一点上，我想我们应该结束了，我们将在下一期播客中带着更多的雕像回来。是的，更多的雕像讨论。再见。再见。谢谢收听《历史的其余部分》，获取额外剧集、抢先体验、无广告收听。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。